the fastest gains in muscle and strength
I ever had in my life was when I started
training with people significantly
stronger than me sure I got the form
fixes where they're like do this
different breathe out different and I
got all the little details that allowed
me to live Stronger Just because of my
form but the biggest thing that impacted
how I saw was how they threw around my
weight like it was a warm-up and I
remember it shifting my perspective and
automatically I started lifting 50 100
pounds plus more on my list because I
wasn't afraid of the weight anymore they
had normalized what I used to think was
heavy as light that applies in business
as much as it does bodybuilding so if
you're trying to make more money in
business the worst thing you can do is
listen to other poor people about how to
get rich what you got to do is go to
people who are way wealthier than you
see how they talk about money sure
you'll get the tactics and the tips and
things like that but the real gain will
come from how you re-set your view of
reality